[Musique]
Caroline Hervé alias kettin est une DJ
de musique électronique qui fait bouger
les dancefloor du monde entier par
exemple ça c'est elle
c'est ici dont le Perche grâce à une
rencontre qu'elle a replongé dans la
passion de son enfant
les chevaux elle a tout quitté pour
s'installer à phraser et rythmer sa vie
entre ces deux passions la musique et sa
jument perceronnes gracieuse de hier
c'est pas le bon rythme là c'est
[Musique]
salut Caroline salut
je me suis dit ça y est festival électro
danceflo et tout et j'arrive écurie
comment on fait pour passer du milieu de
la nuit aux écuries et bien je suis venu
m'installer dans le père d'abord en
résidence secondaire mais au bout d'un
mois je suis venu habiter ici et ça m'a
donné envie de remonter à cheval et me
voici dans cette écurie à monter mon
Percheron on est à Brou qui est au sud
du Perche aux portes de la Beauce
[Musique]
vraiment des nuits agitées en boîte
schizophrène c'est le grand écart quand
je repars dans les clubs j'ai au moins
j'ai des choses à transmettre j'ai de
l'énergie positive bonjour ma beauté
on sent quand même le DJ il y a quand
même un petit truc
entre scratch et tu vois ces petits
boutons là
on va faire une coupe de cheveux
donc je vais te donner ma brosse magique
et si tu appuies là sur la brosse
directement il y a 1982 qui sort
[Musique]
donc c'est pas sur les cheveux c'est
vraiment sur la peau en fait ça ça
enlève la poussière
ta prochaine destination où est-ce que
tu vas après bah ce soir je vais à Paris
et samedi je vais à Lausanne et ensuite
on a une petite tournée aux États-Unis
voilà rien que ça voilà
[Musique]
je maîtrise déjà celui-là et après je
passe à un vrai cheval on y va étape par
étape
[Musique]
pour la sauvegarde de l'espèce il y a
une association aussi c'est ça on a créé
l'association donc cheval percheron
association on voudrait que la race soit
plus connue soit protégé que les gens
découvrent ce trésor du Perche qui est
un ambassadeur international français
bien sous-estimé en tout cas on te sent
apaisé avant de repartir en vadrouille
bon effectivement j'ai pas rencontré
kittine dans un club à New York ni à
Tokyo ni à Berlin ni à Zurich on était
dans le Perche et c'est cool quand même
et bien bien perché aussi